different views on what the
cases mean. Buckle up indeed,
because anything can happen. We
know it will and all that starts
now starts. Right Michael Moore.
Great to see you. Thank you so
much. She ate it. Trump has been
attacking the Manhattan district
attorney, you know for convening
this grand jury and indicting
him in the first place. Trump
accuses D a Alvin Bragg focusing
on him and ignoring what he
calls soaring record crime. In
his borough of Manhattan. CNN's
Daniel Dale joining us now with
the fact check on this and other
claims that trump and other
Republicans are making about the
district attorney, Daniel good
to see you help, sort it all out
for us. Leaving aside the
question of how responsible any
D a is for crime and his
jurisdiction. Trump's claim that
Manhattan crime is at record
highs, as he posted on truth
social is not even close to true
. New York City crime stats are
public so the former president
could look this up. If he truly
wanted to let me show you with
those very public numbers just
how inaccurate trump's claim is
the northern part of Manhattan
had 43 murders last year, and
it's on just about the same pace
early this year. That same
region had 300 79 murders in
1990 almost 10 times as many to
the southern part of Manhattan
had 35 murders last year. It's
on an even better pace this year
versus 124 murders in 1990. It's
not just murder, every kind of
violent crime in Manhattan is
way down from that 1990 peak.
There was an uptick in many
kinds of crime in Manhattan in
2022 compared to 2021, but many
of those categories such as
shooting incidents have come
back down significantly in the
first part of 2023. I'll add
that some trump allies are
making even broader claims that
crime in New York City as a
whole is at a record high. We
saw a New York GOP congressman
Anthony D. Esposito, tweets such
a claim yesterday. That is also
not even close to true. For
example, the city had 438
murders last year, it had 2262
murders in 1990. So again, there
is a huge drop citywide from the
bad old days. Okay Daniel and
you know trump and some
Republicans also claimed that
Bragg is linked to liberal
billionaire donor George Soros.
Can you clear that up for us? So
a spokesman for Soros told me
that Soros has never once
communicated with Bragg in any
way, and we know that Soros did
not make any donations to
Bragg's 2021 election campaign.
What sorrows did do, though, is
make donations to a pac
political action committee that
supported Bragg's campaign
source, is a longtime supporter
of criminal justice reform and
democratic D, a candidates
promoting set reform and his
spokesman told me that he ended
affiliated political action
committee gave $4 million
between 2016 and 2022, including
one million in may 2021 to a pro
reform packed called color of
change. The color of change told
me it ended up spending just
over $500,000 in support of
brides campaign. Color of
change, president Rashad
Robinson told me though, he
says, it's a wild reach to
suggest that color of change is
500 K in spending was like the
one thing that won the election
for Alvin Bragg, who has a
distinguished legal resume and
was way outspent anyway in this
competitive democratic primary.
Even with the color of change
effort, Robinson told me his
group was one of many important
factors in the race. And he said
to me quote up until last week,
we couldn't get people to write
about our pack. Now all of a
sudden, we single handedly
elected the Manhattan when he
was elected. Didn't get that
credit. Robinson also called the
Soros related attacks anti
semitic and anti black. And I
think this is important context
for these sorrows attacks.
Source has been for years
targeted with a centuries old
anti semitic tropes about
sinister, rich jewish puppet
masters, supposedly
orchestrating big events, and
Oren Segal, an executive at the
anti defamation league, which
works to fight anti semitism,
told me that trump's campaign
the trump campaign's own
fundraising emails about Alvin
Bragg have quote increasingly
promoted potentially problematic
language often used as anti
semitic dog whistles, including
calling sorrows, a puppet master
or puppeteer. Now it is
certainly possible. Emphasize
this you can talk about George
Soros is role in races and us
politics. He's an important
political player in this
country. But there's no sign
Alvin Bragg is taking orders
from him on this or anything